- Parce que pour la première
fois au Québec, il y a éclosion
d'un champignon potentiellement
mortel, le Candida auris.
Il a été détecté au début du
mois à l'Hôpital Pierre-Boucher,
à Longueuil. Deux patients
sont infectés, trois autres cas
possibles sont à l'étude.
Une cellule de crise nationale
a été mobilisée. J'en parle
avec le Dr Jasmin Villeneuve, il
est médecin-conseil à l'Institut
national de santé publique du
Québec. Dr Villeneuve, bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Alors on entendait un de vos
confrères se montrer inquiet.
Est-ce que vous l'êtes vous par
cette éclosion dans un hôpital?
Dr JASMIN VILLENEUVE, médecin-
conseil, INSPQ
- Bien en fait, on est toujours
préoccupés quand il arrive
une éclosion avec
un pathologiste nouveau,uveau,u,
qu'on ne connaît pas, pour être
sûr que les mesures sont en
place et connaître la situation.
Mais on inquiets
outre mesure actuellement.
- Mais vous dites que c'est
un pathogène nouveau en fait,
relativement nouveau.
N'est-ce pas?
- En fait, il est nouveau
au Québec, où on a eu quelques
rieurement, dans
les années antérieures.
C'est la première éclosion
rapportée au Québec.C'est un aga
été identifié depuis 2009 en
Asie, qui s'est répandu dans
différents pays dans le monde,
entre autres aux États-Unis
actuellement, il est en
augmentation. Donc il est
relativement nouveau dans
certains endroits plus...
il a plus d'historique ou il est
installé plus dans d'autres
milieux, mais pour le Québec,
il est quand même nouveau.
- Bon, cela dit, c'est
circonscrit, Pierre-Boucher.
Est-ce que c'est dangereux
en ce moment pour le personnel
de l'hôpital ou les autres
patients?
- Il faut savoir que c'est un
champion qui va être dangereux
ou qui va causer des infecti
surtout chez les patients qui
sont très immunosupprimés,
qui ont des maladies chroniques
multiples, qui son
plus à risque de développer
une infection ou de rester
porteur du champignon à long
terme. Pour les personnes en
bonne santé, pour le personnel
ou les gens qui fréquentent
l'hôpital, il n'y a pas de
danger actuellement à travailler
ou à fréquenter l'hôpital
actuellement, malgré l'éclosion
en cours.
- C'est parce qu'on a lu
des choses : apparemment,
il est apparu à l'hôpital Sinaï
à New York, et on a eu beaucoup
de mal à décontaminer
la chambre. Il a fallu qu'on
change des pans de murs entiers.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait, qu'Est-ce
qu'on a fait à Pierre-Boucher
et qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
en faisant de ce champion?
- Ce qu'on connaît de
ce champion, c'est qu'il peut
avoir tendance effectivement
à contaminer l'environnement.
On doit donc appliquer
des mesures de prévention de
désinfection régulière avec
les bons produits. C'est un peu
comme quand on s'occupe d'un
C. difficile, on a besoin
de produits chlorés ou de
peroxyde d'hydrogène. C'est les
mêmes produits qu'on va
utiliser. Il peut arriver dans
un milieu - je ne connais pas la
situation du mont Sinaï - il y a
des fois des milieux où les murs
ou les planchers sont brisés,
sont très difficiles à
désinfecter et à ce moment-là,
la meilleure façon, c'est
de faire un changement
des structures,
des infrastructures qui sont
en place. Mais ce n'est pas de
façon courante qu'on a besoin de
changer tout l'environnement
pour en prendre le contrôle.
- Donc je comprends
qu'il se propage en restant
sur les surfaces des différents
objets, par contact corporel
aussi. Par l'air? Est-ce que
les spores, c'est un champignon
après tout, est-ce qu'il peut
être dans l'air?
Je pose la question.
- En fait, ça fait partie
de la classe des champignons
mais c'est plus une levure,
donc ne va pas faire les spores
de la même façon que d'autres
champignons et il ne se propage
pas par l'air. C'est vraiment
par contact, contact direct,
peau à peau avec une personne,
contact indirect avec
l'environnement, les appareils
utilisés; et il peut rester
effectivement dans
l'environnement si on effectue
pas de désinfection. Quand on
effectue unr désinfection
régulière et adéquate, on peut
arriver à le contrôler.
- Bon, alors pourquoi
est-ce qu'on dit... C'est
un champignon, on voit qu'il est
quand même pas mal contagieux.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'il est
mortel, potentiellement mortel?
- En fait, c'est un champion
qui se démarque de l'ensemble
des champignons des autres
familles, les autres genres de
Candida qu'on connaît, où il va
se transmettre plus facilement
d'une personne à l'autre alors
que les autres Candida se
transmettent moins.
Il peut donner des infections
invasives chez les personnes
à risque : je parlais tantôt
des immunosupprimés ou les
personnes qui ont des maladies
chroniques. Et ces infections
invasives là pourraient amener
au décès, mais c'est des gens
qui ont déjà beaucoup
de pathologies qui vont être
beaucoup plus fragiles pour
les infections. Et aussi...
- Et quand vous dites invasive,
vous voulez dire que c'est
tout le corps. C'est systémique
versus un coin de... un membre
par exemple.
- Exactement, quand on parle
d'invasif, c'est que ça va être
soit un organe interne ou
dans le sang, il va se promener
dans le sang, qui va donner
une infection quand même
très sévère. C'est un organisme
qui a aussi des résistances
aux traitements. Donc il peut
être très difficile à traiter
avec les traitements classiques.
Ce n'est pas toutes les souches
de Candida auris qui ont
les mêmes types de résistances,
mais il peut présenter des
difficultés à être traité,
ce qui fait que ça augmente
encore la possible probabilité
ou la possibilité de donner des
infections sévères qui peuvent
mener au décès. Et c'est ce
qu'on a vu à travers le monde.
Il y a eu quand même beaucoup de
décès, mais chez des personnes
qui étaient déjà très,
très malades.
- Mais j'ai lu quelque part que
le risque d'en mourir de cette
infection atteignait 60 %?
C'est ça?
- Ça, ça va dépendre. C'est sûr
qu'il faut regarder selon les
études, selon les situations.
Et souvent, ce qu'on ne voit
pas, c'est est-ce que
la personne est décédée
de l'infection parce que c'est
un Candida auris ou elle est
décédée parce qu'elle a eu une
infection parce qu'elle était
déjà très malade? C'est pas
toujours évident de faire
la part des choses, où est
la cause, qu'est-ce qui a fait
décéder la personne.
- Aux États-Unis ces endémiques
et courants et dans les
hôpitaux.
On a vu des cas au pays beaucoup
plus rares, mais c'était chez
des patients qui revenaient de
l'étranger, mais pas à Pierre
Boucher. Comment expliquer cette
nouvelle contamination ici?
- Actuellement Québec n'est pas
endémique au présent dans la
population. C'est des situations
qu'on a eues comme la majorité
des cas au Canada, ce sont des
gens qui l'ont emporté
d'ailleurs. Ce qu'c'est que
quelqu'un est arrivé avec et n'a
pas été détecté et aurait pu
donner ce qu'on a trouvé à
Pierre Boucher. C'est l'enquête
qui va déterminer
justement c'est la bonne
hypothèse,
d'où ça vient. Ça ne vient pas
du Québec qu'on appelle être
détecté ailleurs. Comme tout
agent
Avant même la pandémie de
recommandations. Appliquer les
mesures en conséquence et bien
se préparer, c'est d'en avoir eu
le pour n'avoir d'autre, pas des
États-Unis où il y a plus de
cas, pos